[Music]
[Applause]
imagine a utopian world what does your
world look like my world is full of
colors some colors are indescribable the
trees are vibrant and swish in the
gentle breeze Meadows are full of a
variety of bright flowers nature
flourishes next to bustling cities
people are agreeable to one another and
are open into different perspectives my
world lacks ignorant sand overflows with
compassion and understanding for one
another
it is fueled by love my world is fueled
by a love of nature a lot of knowledge a
love of empathy a love for one another
and most of all a love for our future
our children my world is a world where
every child is born with potential and
equal opportunity children are the
future and governments realize this B
invest more into the success and
education of the future it is not a
world ripe with violence or greed but
one of peace and kindness and it most
definitely is a world where each and
every child on the screen have no
obstacles pertaining to the racial and
our ethnic backgrounds while some of the
attributes of my utopian world are
seemingly unattainable others should
make us wonder why is it that the idea
of every child being born with potential
and equal opportunities only one of a
dream world what you may ask isn't that
already something of the present we all
have the same amount of opportunity at
birth right no they do not
we have a problem racial judgements are
ruining children's lives for simplicity
let us define racial judgments as
judgements related to race and ethnicity
we live in a world where a child's
future is almost set in stone the moment
that they are conceived a future that is
primarily dependent on us
our carelessness and our lack of
awareness and making judgments is
destructive to our children our future
yes we have a huge problem but we also
have a great solution take a look at the
group of children projected on the
screen what do you see do you see a
diverse group of children eagerly
waiting to answer we've all determined
that these children are adorable
how old do they look they seem to be in
preschool or a more likely kindergarten
or first grade defusing also this
picture anything else at all have you
made all your observations here are a
few observations that most of you
probably didn't make let's consider a
hypothetical situation this is more or
less your typical preschool class so
let's say that James the white boy in
the first row by solute his hand the
Japanese girl to the right of him
because she wouldn't give him her crayon
on average the worst punishment James
will get is a phone call home and a
timeout fair enough
right okay same situation but let's have
Daniel bite Lily's hand
Daniel is more likely to be suspended if
not expelled in fact black males are
three times more likely to be suspended
than their white counterparts for the
same misbehaves a trend that holds for
preschool as well as the rest of their
educational careers the idea of black
males being persecuted far more severely
than their white counterparts is
prevalent throughout the child's life an
example of this is seen in the school to
Prison Pipeline which states that male
african-americans are more likely to go
to prison straight from school well the
situation above is hypothetical it's
based off of a real-life incident these
racial judgments start in the very
beginning preschool the black girl in
the picture katie is facing consequences
just as extreme it's not more extreme
according to a study conducted by
Columbia University law professor
Kimberly William Crenshaw black girls
and other girls of color
are facing a grave danger while black
boys are only three times more likely to
be suspended black girls are six times
more prone to suspension than their
white female classmates in a Baltimore
school a school security officer claimed
to be attacked by three black girls the
school immediately believed the officer
and expel the three girls however after
reviewing a security tape it was shown
that the officer had repeatedly hit one
of the girls on the head with her baton
and pepper spray the other girls forcing
all three girls to seek treatment at a
hospital why is that why are these girls
in more danger than white girls well the
study goes on to explain that black
girls and other girls of color are seen
as disruptive and ignorant their
achievements are ignored
and their actions are misinterpreted
like for instance the study claims that
the majority of its participants
believed that their teachers viewed them
negatively and often braided them for
being defiant when in fact they were
just being curious furthermore the girls
of color are facing an intersectional
burden since they're darker skin is
associated with aggressive behavior and
as women they have the additional burden
of being seen as bossy and demanding
when they are being assertive thus the
discrimination that girls of color face
can be far more onerous than that of
boys of color because of the difference
in gender racial judgements are ruining
children's lives not only black children
other children as well one was seeing an
Asian person we immediately assumed that
they must be super smart
that being said white people also have
to deal with racial judgments they are
typically taken as more racist and more
judgmental than any other race consider
this picture of teens from different
ethnic backgrounds speaking out against
the racial judgements day combat these
judgments are based off of stereotypes
and these generalizations have become
jokes we have forgotten that our words
can actually do damage let's not forget
the racial judgments concerning religion
the Pew Research Center
doctor to survey where they asked
Americans to rate how warmly they felt
about Muslims on a thermometer scale
from 0 degrees to 100 degrees the
average temperature was 40 degrees
significantly cooler than that of the
rest of the seven religious groups are
also surveyed this is because one they
base their judgment off of a small
percentage of extremist Muslims and two
they're ignorant to what the religion
actually stands for this is a problem I
myself faced as the young Muslim woman
racial judgments are the reason why I a
16 year old girl and pulled aside during
airport security while I understand that
was for my own safety it's tiring and
concerning that the people around me may
be afraid of me or hate me because of a
piece of clothing my hijab on my head
these types of racial judgments will
surely affect alia the Indian Muslim
girl in the back row I like the majority
of Muslims as well as the majority of
the world absolutely abhor terrace in
every group of people there's always
going to be a small percentage of people
who are so extreme that the larger group
must disown them but no matter how we
try to separate ourselves from these
criminals our physical similarities are
too much for people to overcome simply
because we share the same color of skin
or piece of clothing with you saris we
become targets of the same racial
judgments in our nation many of us hold
ideals that race shouldn't matter now
most of us have overcome almost all
racial barriers and problems caused by
race our statement is a half truth it is
true that most of us have overcome
racial barriers concerning friendship
and other aspects of life however there
are still so many aspects of our lives
where race unfortunately still matters
in many cases our racial backgrounds
determine the level of educational
opportunity we have the types of lives
we will lead and the way we are
perceived by society
we shouldn't always ignore race
sometimes knowing a person's beliefs or
race can help you become more respectful
towards that person it can broaden your
horizons and help you form judgments
that aren't biased and/or ignorant we
can't stop racial judgments or judgments
altogether judging is an evolutionary
trait something we needed for a survival
simple judgments like knowing what to
cross the street or knowing not to go
into a dark alleyway at night are
essential for human life which is why
stopping racial judgements is nearly
impossible and detrimental to our
species here's what we can do we can
become aware of our racial judgements
our awareness will make us think twice
about our judgments it has proven that
actively looking for biases and your
racial judgments will make your
judgments more accurate and respectful
this is because racial judgments are
products of implicit bias a bias in
assumptions and behavior that occur on a
subconscious level it is due to the
assumptions and stereotypes that we are
exposed to in our respective
environments implicit bias is automatic
but it's not intransigent awareness is
the key next time we find ourselves
making an assumption about someone we
need to ask ourselves why do we have a
good reason would you be able to justify
our assumption to someone with a
different perspective when we ask
ourselves these questions we tend to
second-guess ourselves and in this case
this is a good thing if we second-guess
ourselves our racial judgments will
become more accurate more respectful and
less biased I'm not saying this will be
easy it's hard I'm ashamed to admit that
I have succumbed to bias racial
judgments I've walked down the street
with my best friend and we have
deliberately changed our pace or route
to avoid an african-american or right
man in baggy clothing but I think we're
taking the first step in making better
racial judgements when we realize that
some of our judgments are biased
I've often found myself judging someone
without realizing and then mentally
berating myself right after so become
more aware after solves the reasons
behind your judgments and assumptions
this will help you become more aware of
your judgments and of your thoughts it's
not for your own sake for the sake of
those little preschoolers for the sake
of our world's future this awareness
will brighten our world creating a safe
space for all of our children to thrive
and achieve their hopes and dreams and
someday my utopian world our utopian
world will become a reality thank you
[Applause]